only because I see Rihanna is here and
I'm gonna say I'm gonna say something
very controversial Rihanna you take all
the time you want on that album girl
don't let these fools on the internet
pressure you into nothing
yeah Rihanna's long-awaited album gets a
shout out at the Golden Globes followed
by some laughs from her and ASAP Rocky
yes you're still gonna get music from me
but hey at least rere's trademark style
gets some love too Rihanna I love you
and I dressed up as you for Halloween I
just had to say that all right and had
to take my moment wait is every
presenter a member of the Navy if I
believed in Halloween I would have
dressed up as Rihanna as well
this is what we love is like when the
nominations help you write the story
Rihanna Taylor Swift Lady Gaga I mean
heavyweights big stars big stars than
that yep the best original song category
had quite the lineup with Rihanna
Landing a nod for her song on the Black
Panther wakanda forever soundtrack
[Music]
she's a person who marches to the beat
of Her Own Drum I'm just thankful that
she she wanted to she wanted to
contribute to this she is a big one man
she is she is the one and only Rihanna
lost to the Maestro behind last year's
Global hit RR we're calling him the pop
diva Slayer yes Taylor Swift Lady Gaga
Rihanna you beat them all all of them
are my favorites yes but 2023 is just
getting started for Rihanna hitting the
field next month for the Super Bowl
halftime show you know what I want to
incorporate
a lot of culture I want to incorporate
different aspects of
entertainment and things that I just
enjoy and bring it to the stage
[Music]
thank you